c'est une scène qu'on n'aurait jamais
imaginé les employés quittent lemon
Brothers avec leur possession un géant
de la finance fondé en 1850 s'effondre
le 15 septembre 2008
le ventre panique souffle sur Wall
Street qui enregistre ses plus
importantes pertes depuis les attentats
du World Trade Center par
Washington refuse de racheter lemon
Brothers à mon avis de laisser tomber
les menottes une grave erreur et si on
n'avait pas changé de route par la suite
le système bancaire américain aurait pu
s'effondrer et avec lui le système
financier mondial
pour éviter les cartons le gouvernement
lance une grande opération de sauvetage
au coût de 700 milliards de dollars
en plus des constructeurs automobiles
les États-Unis prennent possession d'un
cinquième du système bancaire en
quelques mois on a essentiellement
nationalisé le système financier pendant
un petit bouton on n'avait jamais pensé
dans un pays capitaliste qu'on avait vu
ça
les États-Unis entrent en récession en
raison de la crise du papier commercial
les banques gourmandes ont octroyé des
prêts hypothécaires trop risqués la
bulle immobilière éclate quand la
Réserve fédérale américaine augmente ses
taux d'intérêt les banques ont commencé
à donner des
normalement il y aurait pro éthique
le rêve américain se transforme en
cauchemar la crise frappe les ménages de
plein fouet à Cleveland des quartiers
disparaissent sous le poids de
l'économie
d'Américains perdent leur maison tous
les jours les banques ne sachant plus
quoi faire des propriétés les détruisent
faute d'acheteurs un véritable désastre
du plein d'emplois on a eu une
augmentation du taux de chômage assez
élevé les taux d'intérêts ont du B c'est
beaucoup ça a pris du temps avant que
les gens se sentent confiants à
continuer à investir dans l'économie
américaine sans intervention publique
massive telle qu'il a été fait durant en
2008 on aurait eu une crise bancaire
sans précédent c'est peut-être la leçon
attirée de 2008 certaines banques trop
importantes pour faire faillite doivent
être sauvés avant qu'elles n'emporte le
système financier en entier ici
Jean-Philippe piouze Radio-Canada
Montréal